à cosne-sur-loire ils sont trois hommes
encore briguer la mairie en tête du
premier tour avec près de 35% des voix
le maire sortant michel venot se veut
serein
ils pensent pouvoir conserver un mandat
qu'il a déjà dû occuper deux mois de
plus en raison de la crise sanitaire
une élection n'est jamais gagnée
d'avancé mais je pense que on a essayé
nous pendant depuis les élections de
bien faire notre travail d'assumer nos
fonctions et on a continué de faire
notre travail comme on devait le faire
comme est un élu doit le faire dans sa
commune on n'a pas un mot qu on parlait
des élections municipales j'ai dit on
verra plus tard face au maire actuel et
son prédécesseur c'est un nouveau venu
qui a décroché la deuxième place avec
seulement son voix de retard pour le
second tour daniel gilles signé entend
incarner la seule alternative pour les
électeurs qui désire un changement qui
aujourd'hui peut remplacer cette
majorité contenu des scores du premier
tour
alors si c'est pas nous qui choisissent
notre liste socialiste quelque part on
revient pas
reviens pas six ans on n'a rien on
revient 12 en troisième avec 23 7 % des
suffrages
alain dherbier espère toujours récupérer
le fauteuil abandonné en 2014
car pour lui les scores ont été faussées
par l'abstention massive au premier tour
quantité de qu'on doit m'en interpellé
sur le marché en me disant mais ce
dernier ya là même qui m'appelle
toujours monsieur le maire il faut
absolument avoir présenté on ne peut
plus supporter la gestion de la ville
telle qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui
alors quand je vois le résultat bush et
sur paille pour faire tomber le maire
sortant en position de force certains
anticipent et déjà une fusion des listes
de ses opposants les discussions ont
échoué car daniel gilles ollier a refusé
une alliance de circonstance contre
laquelle il s'était engagé
je cacherai pas que j'ai eu un ou deux
coups de téléphone me propose en fusion
choses comme ça ça vient pas de moi on
est bien d'accord puisque lors de mes
réunions ou dans les les articles des
journaux j'avais bien spécifié que si
j'arrivais dans les deux premiers je
maintiendrai avec la même liste c'est
une solution
1 en principe quand il ya une
triangulaire c'est rare s'il n'y a pas
d'accord au deuxième tour entre deux
listes bon je pense que là aussi les
nouveaux dans le dans la démarche c'est
un peu particulier mais bon c'est pas
grave
l'inconnue du second tour c'est la
participation à peine 45 % au premier
les candidates pertes un rebond pour
éviter les questions de légitimité
j'espère que les gens pourront se
déplacer parce que il est soit à pour
les élus qu'on ait au moins 50 % de
votants serait bien qu'on ait environ
50% de votants pour permettra aux élus
qui n'a pas trop de critiques derrière
par rapport même à la population guinée
doit vous avez été élu et qu'un petit
score reste à savoir également ce que
feront les électeurs de michel mézy
ancien adjoint de michel venot éliminé
au premier tour car c'est 300 voix
pourrait bien être décisive dans cette
triangulaire